Instagram is weird now a days do you do
you notice that like your explore page
and everything it's just the most [ __ ]
up [ __ ] like the most let me look
controversial
like yeah there's a guy jumping right
here on Instagram yeah I feel like
they're tweaking the algorithm like
they're turning it up to 15 because they
want to compete with tech talk is yours
like that or is it just my shitty
algorithm yeah dude it's like mine's
really like mine's really scary mine's
really scary
okay this is a green waste car but it's
not very that's your explore Pages cars
yeah dude
yep because I'm sick as [ __ ] yeah yours
is scary because you're weird
Noel's is sick yeah I guess that's true
I went I went and looked at one I went
and looked at Sea bum you know sebum yep
I went looked at his Instagram page one
time I want to see how you know I want
to see what see my boy lives Mr Olympia
three-time class this is what you're
into right physique guys working out you
love watching that type of zero
now your Instagram is gonna be [ __ ]
Luke or whoever's Instagram this is I
think it's ours you're making it sound
like you went to this page and then your
whole thing became just like it's
bodybuilder the whole explore page now
is bodybuilders but it's not just them
at competition it's them like injecting
steroids screaming at each other just
doing the most [ __ ] up [ __ ] crazy
poses their muscles tearing like
everything
it's like oh you like this here's the
worst parts of this thing I think um do
you like a lot of stuff that has to do
with your training or something like a
lot of fitness
I don't really like anything on
Instagram I just you know I don't think
you have to I don't think you have to
like it
I mean they're [ __ ] double tap and
everything yeah
[ __ ] that one's [ __ ] sick weird
every one of these pictures says liked
by Cody I thought it was I thought it
was wait I thought it was mandatory I
thought you you happy isn't that how it
works like your boys post yeah dude no I
I got a sick body though
Instagram Pages aren't [ __ ] up your
explore feet is not no but what I was
gonna say was I don't think you have to
like it I think if you just watch
something long enough Instagram yeah you
like it so you're watching guys like
tear their pecs when they're hitting
bench or what is it yeah it's just like
now my whole feed is just these gnarly
ass bodybuilders getting hurt kissing
each other
it's crazy
rubbing each other down yeah they're
just like rubbing oils I don't know
yeah it's sex is it weird crazy and I
don't understand what's going on and I
stay on it for hours because the
algorithm makes you you know exactly
exactly touches that part of your brain
it's like you have no choice yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's my own feed
guys the algorithm's so [ __ ] like all
right it's a [ __ ]
you're commenting guys nice nice real
real
unreal lats dude double tap man so
[ __ ] up
sebum keep doing your thing man
I love you please notice me
hater the comments I'm real glute
definition my man
double tap
bodybuilders are are such interesting
people because they're
I am fascinated by it I mean they're
just living rotisserie chickens like
they're
[Music]
[Laughter]
fine
what the hell is this Bernie has said
she doesn't Vibe with straight men does
she feel okay here
what the hell what's up it says that
right there on the topic stuff I don't
see dude that's on your famous birthdays
bio
hey Brittany it's your birthday is it
okay if we put this on your profile it's
scared of men yeah Brittany does not
Vibe with CIS head men facts
it takes very
very takes a very special type of fella
who's the last straight dude you hung
out with do you know Jack Eminem Harry
Styles well
Jack Kinnon oh is it you're saying he's
not straight check in and then no he's
Canadian do you know him who Jack in and
Harry Styles
I don't know who we're talking about
anymore Drake Drake Drake Drake yeah
Drake yes you guys don't know him jack
that's my buddy Jack he is so sexy and
hot it makes me really upset oh he's
funny he's on Tick Tock right oh he's
yeah he's super Kane I just saw a video
of him being like what's really super
cute yeah how do I get him on my explore
page he's super cute Canadian who the
[ __ ] what post do I have to like to get
this guy from my explore page like like
I just saw a video of him where he's
like talking about how you know all the
all the Frat kids in the States now
using like Canadian lingo Toronto men I
thought that was pretty funny yeah
because it's true like milk did that
like everyone is talking about smoking
darts and all the stuff that's like was
from the East Coast Canada yeah and now
so much of that just is frat boy culture
in America too like in the South they're
like
speak English no but anyway you're
speaking Canadian yeah but that never
used to be the case whatever Fred dudes
won't be like you got a [ __ ] dart on
you they never would say that [ __ ] no I
had one friend in college in my
fraternity who was from Toronto and he
would say that and all of a sudden it
was like the funniest thing ever
like dialect that frat guys just kind of
adopt yeah would you yeah but if they
adopted the Canadian yeah because of
nelk I'm pretty sure yeah the milk boys
spread that around [ __ ] a that's
really weird
to go to Oklahoma they're like hey bud
you got a dart on you yeah you're like
I'm about to puff down oh don't be a
[ __ ] birdie over here yeah at the
Polish bird
it's literally like at a m frat guys are
like that like it is a disease it's
everywhere is that crazy it is like a
rip a fat piss in the shittery hey
you're from Dallas Texas
you're from Texas rip a piss in the
[ __ ] that's a [ __ ] great that's
great original Jack says that rip a piss
in the [ __ ] rip a fat piss in the
shittery with my [ __ ] butt that just
sounds like forced vernacular yeah
Travis practicing in the mirror rip a
piss in this [ __ ] or rip a piss in the
[ __ ] yeah eating up you think fried
guys do that yeah sound like milk sound
like milk come on they're looking in the
mirror no this little bird no no wrong
no I think they try it out one time in
front of the boys you know they hit a
you got a dart on you yeah yeah dude
what yeah what do you know like no no
like a dart who's milk oh dude you gotta
watch their videos
you're that guy that makes everyone
crowd around an iPhone oh dude look I'm
just turning it up I'm trying to you
know music's too loud hold on let me put
it in a cup no this video over half the
screen you can't see Steve oh he's so
funny no listen please listen it's so
funny no look give me the pill like just
pause the music for a second like let's
just watch this real quick bill give me
anyone have a JBL yeah and then the
music just cuts out and this is like
what up boys right here and [ __ ]
everyone's
yeah that's why I'm glad I didn't go to
college
because I'd be at some [ __ ] Kickback
if someone would be like what do you
mean Mr hands let's go to the TV real
quick
I'll just be there like two other people
and everyone's like pre-gaming in the
kitchen they're like yo what the [ __ ] is
that on the TV
all right it's turning around man if
you're not feeling it
back to the music videos
in a second yo this is perverse family
you guys I thought you'd like this you
seen perverse family oh that's a that's
harassment we can't even yeah we can't
we can't even show that you can only
show that the who do we show Spock we
showed the Spock okay yeah that was yeah
you can't but if you know if you if you
feel so compelled on your own maybe look
it up if you want to or no or don't
actually
don't do that yeah never mind do it
don't look it up oh I will don't you
pick my curiosity
it's the most [ __ ] up thing you could
ever what's the nastiest thing you've
seen on the internet I recently went on
[ __ ] H3 and Ethan showed me a video
of two prolapsed [ __ ] rubbing
against each other
so that's actually really awesome
because I had an answer ready to go yeah
yeah so we probably could watch perverse
family right now
I'm kidding I'm kidding pull it up I'm
kidding I'm kidding don't pull it up do
not pull it up I mean it was like I
haven't felt that jarring like holy [ __ ]
why did he show you that hey that's a
great question he's just out of nowhere
well no there is a backstory you know
Howie Mandel's Tick Tock yes yeah yeah
yeah what was that one again he just
looked the camera like look at this
prolapse no he said is this coven
related and if so what do we do about it
his prolapsed [ __ ] right
um it wasn't his oh it was his it was
his own yeah Oh I thought no it wasn't
it was Ethan's no
just spreading rumors why were they
rubbing them together it was a porn
video
because it like a butterfly kiss but
like in Australia or something but it's
a deleted scene from mid-summer yeah
producer rosebuds some religious
ceremony yeah
someone's view oh my God that sound
awful noise somehow nailed it terrible
noise yeah hey can't confirm though that
is very close yeah more or less hell
yeah uh yeah he showed me and he was
damn we didn't know you were chill like
that Bernie
I know you guys talk about prolapsed
anuses
yeah they showed me that video and I
mean Ethan's just cracking up and I'm
like electroshocked out of my body and
then back into my body because that was
like holy [ __ ] and of course he can't
show it but oh my God I wish he could I
wish he could well pull up perverse man
don't do not do not
how do we always end up here man like
scroll up I love the beginning of this
like topics is so like Morning Show so
Britney got a recently got a new tattoo
yeah when I stopped we [ __ ] end up
every time
hands and horses asses
when I saw this doc
you know I laughed and I said if they
think
I'ma sit down and go I heard you got a
tattoo
Brittany you guys are out of here got a
new tattoo mine
tell us about that okay that's so Random
of you to do that it's a piece of bacon
it's a mustache right here on my finger
so I can go burp
[Music]
Derpy no that's literally some rip of
you yeah